[Music]
hey there everyone it is i monster maze
normally i'm not the one to do topical
videos but hey it's breath of the wild
too we gotta talk about this news about
this game is few and far between so i
might as well give my two cents on the
matter this will be one of those rare
times where i'm completely off script i
haven't written anything down so please
bear with me and forgive me for all the
stumbling so nintendo put up a new video
about the development stage of brevtuatu
and first of all adrian numa my man
looking good with his new hairdo i guess
quarantine is officially over in japan
so yeah the game has officially been
delayed to 2023. now to be honest as the
optimist that i am this was not in my
line of expectations i mean i didn't
rule out the possibility but since they
announced the release here only about
nine months ago i thought they were
pretty confident that they were gonna
make it but well apparently not on the
one hand this is kinda disappointing
obviously having to wait longer is never
fun but at the same time i think it
would benefit the game to be honest 2022
is so incredibly packed we got horizon
forbidden west alden ring kirby god of
war is on the way xenoblade chronicles 3
star field hogwarts legacy which by the
way looks amazing has been announced for
december and i'm pretty sure i'm
forgetting even more especially with a
game like elden ring which took the
world by storm and is already being
compared to breath the wild in many ways
i think this is a good opportunity to
give breath to altoo some room to
breathe now i'm not gonna speculate
whether or not this means the game will
be released with new hardware i mean i
hate talking about switch pro and rumors
like that i mean who the heck knows at
this point you know so instead let's
focus on what we do know from the
announcement itself first of all notice
how onuma says that the game will not
just take place on the surface but also
in the skies above which we already knew
from the second teaser however that the
expanded world goes beyond that which is
great news a lot of people were kind of
worried about the surface of hyrule
being revisited including me because
well we already explored this world
extensively and justifyingly so there
were doubts if the sky was going to be
enough to make the game feel fresh and
new and not just a glorified dlc so to
speak and well the man himself agra
seems to put our hearts at ease and
there will be more than just a familiar
surface and the sky what exactly this
expanded world entails of course we
don't know right now the usual stuff
comes to mind like a new province new
islands underground underwater things
which have been theorized before but to
get actual confirmation that there will
be more is again absolutely great news
and to top it off aunuma states that
there will be even more gameplay
elements more encounters and an even
wider variety of features he really
seems to hammer home the fact that this
will be a very different experience and
finally let's go over the new footage
because despite the disappointing
announcement they actually did show some
new stuff not a whole lot but hey it's
something this entire sequence although
brief only lasting a few seconds does at
least confirm two things number one
link's face is just fine no scars or
deformities no malice eyes big hand
everybody he's okay i guess that theory
goes out the window
and two he still has the master sword
it's just that well it's not exactly in
great shape so the whole idea that the
sword fell into the chasm and maybe
zelda has it that goes out the window
too this basically confirms that the
attack on link's arm by malice was
indeed ganondorf going after the master
sword and for good reason it's like the
one thing capable of inflicting mortal
damage to him so that is a sweet power
move by g-man over here it also suggests
that the game will likely revolve around
restoring the master sword as without it
link won't even be able to hurt
ganondorf or at least not kill him of
course this would also mean that the
game cannot be beaten like breath of the
wild where you could just go straight to
calamity ganon and kick his ass that's
not gonna work if you don't have the
tools to do it this could suggest that
the game will have a more linear
approach of course the restoration of
the master sword could still be done out
of order in fact i'm expecting that you
probably can but it won't be as easy as
just walking up to the castle i'm
definitely considering making a more
comprehensive theory about this because
i have a lot of ideas but for now i'll
just say that it's becoming more and
more likely that the sky islands are
indeed tied to the triforce or the
sacred realm in some way we know from
previous games that the master sword's
power to repel evil is something sacred
something tied to sages and the gods and
so on in breath of the wild however
there were no sages at least not in the
traditional sense we only had the four
champions but that's not really the same
thing sages have some sort of special
connection to the gods and as we saw in
the wind waker they can pray to the gods
to restore the master sword's power the
closest thing we saw in breath of the
wild were the sheikah monks at the end
of the trial of the sword which did
indeed restore the sacred glow to the
blade but after they did their bodies
disappeared and their spirits seemed to
have moved on to the afterlife so that
doesn't seem to be an option anymore the
only other entity we saw capable of
restoring the master sword was the deku
tree who is set to tap into some sort of
sacred energy to fix the blade and lo
and behold as many have pointed out the
deku tree seems to be gone in breath the
wall too he's no longer where he should
be so it really seems like ganondorf
tried to eliminate every option to fix
the sword again for good reason lastly i
will quickly touch upon two more things
first is this yellow flame hovering in
front of link i'm not entirely sure but
i get the impression that it's talking
to him the way link has his arm out and
staring right at it and then turning
around to grab the master sword
definitely suggests as much and if it is
indeed sentient the most logical
conclusion is that it's probably the
spirit of whoever this hand belonged to
you know the one that was clutching onto
ganondorf's body which could mean that
we're looking at a new companion
character someone who knows how to
restore the master sword and guides link
on his way who this character is we
don't know of course maybe it's a past
hero or an ancient sage of some kind
we'll just have to wait and see you are
more than welcome to share your
suggestions lastly we do see that link
has some sort of symbol on his hand and
this is definitely not the triforce
instead it's probably tied to the race
or tribe this being belongs to my
current take is that after the attack on
the master sword and link's arm link
will go unconscious which will no doubt
also serve as the excuse to start with
three hearts again and the new footage
likely takes place close to just after
he wakes up when he first realizes what
happened and the spirit inside his arm
will explain how to fix it in fact on
the floor we can see a circular design
with symbols on it very similar to this
shot where link is seemingly half naked
and unconscious and the spirit possesses
his arm and here too we see the same
type of symbols on the floor obviously
in this shot it's almost completely dark
so probably on the ground so my best
guess at this point is that maybe this
entire platform he's laying on will rise
into the sky which would explain how he
gets to the sky for the first time and
that is all i have to say about it at
least for now again don't hesitate to
share your thoughts in the comments
below i'd love to hear what you guys
have to say this is dawn signing off and
have a good one